Now, we just measured
the error of this linear model
against our original training data.
We know, though, from say,
k and n, that we can build models that
can fit this training data exactly.
So we can have arbitrarily small
error against our training set.
The more important measure is,
what is our error out of sample?
So, what out of sample means is
we train on our training set, but
we test on a separate
testing set of data.
And, that's going to be
different than our training set.
So, to measure out of sample error, we
look at the error from our testing set,
not our training set.
So we look at each one of these test
points and measure the error for
each one of those.
So we look at these blue points
instead of the green points,
plug them into this equation
just like before, and
that's our out of sample
root mean squared error.